mon petit n'a pas été mis en place et
donc du coup on est rentré en résistant
civils après à la fin de cet ultimatum
et donc du passé quad en 1025 jour en
2025 jours c'est pas il n'ya pas le
valais va pas y avoir la fin du monde
alors arrivé directement
gdc juste de
dire qu'il nous reste une très petite
fenêtre d'action une très petite et en
fait c'est dans les deux à trois ans
qu'on peut encore faire quelques places
corse et sarah aimerait que ce sera trop
tard il a mis 28 jours c'est que madame
et 28 jours ok ce sera pas la fin du
monde mais ce sera trop tard ça trop
tard voilà c'est ça c'est ça qu'est ce
que vous avez complété le monde dans
lequel tulle enfin quels calculs savants
calculs comme enfin comment vous le
concrétiser cette histoire deux jours
vous avez fait des destructeurs que
l'étude
c'est les deux à trois ans qui nous
restent avant qu'on dépasse donc si tu
es le meilleur d'accord ça calcule les
points de bascule quand le point après
si vous voulez vraiment qu'on parle
climat et qu'on parlait point de bascule
on pourra revenir avec un espère du geiq
je pense pas que ça soit exactement pour
savourer ce soir mais en gros c'est
scientifiquement prouvé on a déjà
dépassé les 25 degrés on veut juste
essayer de ne pas dépasser les 2 degrés
sur si on attendait ce degré juste ces
100 millions de morts sur les routes
c'est un milliard de personnes qui vont
devoir bouger et vont aller où oui ça va
être catastrophique a bien conscience
que c'est sa première solution chez moi
c'est je pose c'est trop petit
si on fait rien les plans qu'on peut
avoir même heure avant de en raison mais
oui non mais tu en parles et signal de
jarnac si les plans en fait pour le
futur mais le problème c'est que si on
n'agit pas dans les deux à trois ans le
reste tous les plans futurs ça sera pas
possible ce qui va être possible et ce
qui va être le cas ces gens dégâts des
familles c'est le chaos c'est la
destruction de la travers quelques jours
pairs chacun
invitation ouverte on va sur les routes
le monde u17 a envie de venir viens voir
ce qui se passait dans les routiers
petit du coup on va polluer qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire l'avion qu'une fois par
an non mais non mais ça en 16 ans portée
des messages et y ait une demande une
rénovation on a une demande c'est la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments on
s'adresse au gouvernement c'est quoi ça
outre la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments ça consistant qui paye ça et
on fait quoi et qui paye la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments c'est la
rénovation globale et performante donc
c'est à dire voyez une maison il ya un
toit il ya des fenêtres il ya une chose
à faire pour être performant et du coup
ne pas avoir trop chaud ni trop froid et
ne pas trop consommer du coup pour
essayer d'avoir un habitabilité normal
dans un appartement en gros faut isoler
sa maison mais le problème jonas et vous
pensez que les vignerons de quoi payer
par les actions de leurs maisons là ils
ont pas de quoi faire le gouvernement
s'engage à déjà mais le gouvernement
c'est avec les impôts des français les
gens ils sont pas prêts pour payer en a
qui peuvent pas payer un choix payer 2
c'est un choix certes rédigé par dix et
d'accords de margerie impôts a jailli
dans quoi mais regarde moi je te tutoie
moi j'ai changé les fenêtres j'ai fait
d'isola annonçant que faire
mais c'est celui que j'ai mis le truc
j'ai tout mis à 19 degrés il ya des gens
qui seront pas aidés par l'état et qui
changeront pas leurs fenêtres